[Music]
rachel's in orange county california hi
rachel welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much this is like my
fourth or fifth time calling and i'm
excited every time
well we're honored to have you again how
can we help thank you
okay so um in january this year i paid
off
two car collections that i had from
about six to seven years ago
um and so one of them is not on my
credit report anymore
the other one for toyota i had to
dispute twice
and it finally shows that i paid a
lesser amount than what was actually due
however it's still showing up on my
credit report and it's saying it'll be
on there until february of next year
that's because that's what happened
okay so they keep that on record for a
year
i mean as long you you settled it for
less than was owed right
correct i got it all in writing yeah so
and and they're reporting
they're reporting it accurately although
it is a negative report
okay is that correct yes okay yeah you
can't do anything about something that's
reported accurately
okay but they're they're saying it's
going to drop off in a year
yeah it says on file until february of
2022.
oh great because yeah but another way
they can another way they can choose to
do it is
seven years from the date of last
activity on the account and the last
activity on the account was when you
settled it
it could have been seven years from the
other day but the good news is it's
about to run out anyway so it's going to
go away
but there's not really anything you can
do about it because you can only dispute
things on a credit bureau report that
are inaccurate
correct and this is accurate so you're
stuck with it and the great news is it's
going to go away
automatically in a year anyway because
apparently that's seven years ago that
you had this
repo or had the problem or establish the
account or something
because it's a seven-year rule the only
thing that stays on your credit bureau
report longer than seven years is a
chapter seven bankruptcy
which will stay on for 10 years but
everything else drops off in seven years
from the date of last activity
uh and so it literally can be you you
pay an old bad bill this week
seven years from this week it goes off
that it can be
but apparently sometimes the cred it's
up to the creditors to how they report
it
but apparently the creditor here is
reporting it from the date the loan was
initially made or
the date that it went into default or
something yeah rachel i just want to
encourage you
hey you're walking out the baby steps so
this isn't going to be a factor for you
anyway number one it doesn't stain you
number two you don't need
it because you're gonna pay cash for
things so let this thing i
love the intensity and i love the
enthusiasm and the deep passion here
but uh this is not a big stain that's
gonna hold you back it's gonna fall off
and you're doing all the right things
really really proud of you keep after it
yeah
here's to ken's point um and it's not
what you were saying so i'm not
correcting you but i just want our
listening audience to hear this clearly
uh we don't worship at the altar of the
great fico
your your fico score is an indication of
how much money you have borrowed and
paid back
it is not an indication of wealth
let me try that again your fico score is
how much the larger your fico score the
more you've been playing kissy face with
the bank
or kissy something and so you got to
decide
you're going to play kissy with the bank
all the time you can have a big old fico
score and keep them rich
if you were going to quit borrowing
money your fico score literally does not
matter
you know what my fico score is i don't
have one it's zero
because i haven't borrowed money shame
on you dave
you have not maximized the american way
yes i have i'm getting several hundred
million dollars is working out for me
so you know this is you know this is but
you're right that you know
it doesn't matter who cares that it's on
there she's moving on yeah yeah she
and i think that's a good point but also
a good point to say she's doing really
good stuff by
really watching what's going on with it
and getting the proper things on there
the proper things off of there i did all
of that too
i wanted to make sure mine was cleaned
off because uh you know after i went
through a bankruptcy it stayed on there
10 years
wow you know yeah and so i
yeah but you know what i never borrowed
money again so it really didn't come up
that's exactly right and she did it
right she got it in writing the
settlement she's doing everything the
right way
yeah she's just really cleaning things
up good good job rachel well played